we'll be learning more about resident
evil 8 very soon
and video revealed their new line of
gpus and ps5 devs
talk about the ssd i'm lucy and these
are the biggest gaming news stories for
tuesday september 1st 1885.
[Music]
capcom said that we'll be learning more
about resident evil village in
august and well we didn't but don't
worry we're getting more news
very very soon resident evil village
will be shown during tokyo game show
which will air between september 23rd
and 27th village will be part of
capcom's lineup obviously
and that will air on the 27th the
announcement trailer for village debuted
in june showing the return of ethan
winters and chris redfield
in the village with strange symbols
really creepy townspeople
witches and of course even a werewolf
village will be coming to ps5
xbox series x and pc in 2021 and like
most of us i'm also holding out for a
full remake
but i'll just be excited about village
for now this morning
nvidia unveiled its new 30 series of
gpus
the 3090 3080 and 3070.
all three include hdmi 2.1 support rt
and tensor cores and ray tracing and
dlss supports we have specs for all up
on gamespot.com but the big takeaways
the 3090 is said to be capable of 60
frames per second gaming
at 8k resolution the 3080 launches first
on september 17th and will cost around
700
the 1390 launches on september 24th for
1500
and the 3070 comes in october and will
cost
only 500 the nvidia live stream also
included some spiffy new trailers for
cyberpunk 2077
call of duty cold war and fortnite which
will soon add ray tracing and dlss
support
for nvidia cards i don't know about you
but the latter half of it this year
is getting so expensive a new
playstation blog post
features some ps5 devs who are talking
about how the console's 3d audio and
ssd are being used in their games
spider-man miles morales creative
director brian horton said the ssd will
give the game
near instant loading and fast travel we
saw this in the ratchet and clank
gamescom demo too
the game lets you instantly travel
between different worlds via portals
resident evil village executive producer
jen takaruchi said
the 3d audio was almost made
specifically with horror games in mind
and horizon forbidden west game director
matthias deyoung says
the 3d audio will help you identify
which direction a threat is coming from
the ps5 is coming out this holiday but
we still don't know
exactly which day or how much it'll cost
and finally ubisoft revealed there will
be another ubisoft forward
next thursday september 10th at 12 p.m
pacific
they teased the announcement with a
trailer featuring watch dogs legion
rainbow six siege immortals phoenix
rising aka gods and monsters
as well as some more surprises keep your
eyes peeled on youtube.com
gamespot and gamespot.com for all the
biggest announcements
i'm on twitter lucyjamesgames and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you